this train station is highly
controversial since last year West
Kowloon station in Hong Kong has
connected the city to the Chinese
mainland I am now standing at the top of
this railway station the rooftop is
accessible as a sightseeing point the
government promotes this station as a
way to access China's vast high-speed
rail network and it highlights that
travel time to Guangzhou the metropolis
of southern China is now half of what it
was before the 130 kilometer train
journey to Guangzhou takes just 45
minutes Beijing 2000 kilometers away can
be reached in nine hours
but many Hong Kongers do not appreciate
this new transport facility in each
again general secretary of the
Confederation of trade unions is one of
them you know it's like a spear frosting
in the heart of Hong Kong the reason for
its discontent inside the railway
station there is a controlled border
between Hong Kong and Mainland China an
official video explains the consequences
attention after entering the mainland
port area departing passengers will need
to comply with mainland laws the
opposition sees this as a breach of Hong
Kong's one country two systems'
arrangement that guarantees hong kong
its own rule of law it's a gradual
slippery slope where gradually you know
chinese begin to intervene now into our
rule of law and then take away a piece
of land and claim it to be chinese
judicial system for many people in hong
kong this station has become yet another
symbol for the mainland's influence in
the city in hong kong tens of thousands
are marching again against the
territorial government this rally was
expected to end outside a train station
linking Hong Kong to the Chinese
mainland the activists want to raise
awareness among tourists arriving from
mainland China about what they consider
anti-democratic policy proposals the
protests were sparked several weeks ago
by a bill that would allow Hong Kong to
extradite suspects to mainland China the
government put the bill on hold DWS
matías boyega is in Hong Kong mattias
thanks for joining us what exactly are
people trying to achieve today well
today at the score of this is still this
extradition bill that is shelved but not
withdrawn by the government but the
whole issue has become much broader it's
about the governance of Hong Kong people
want to make sure that their voice
continues to be heard they want to be
they want to be on the agenda they do
not want the government get away with
just postponing the bill and not making
any other changes so today is really
more of a statement that says we are
still here they are marching in Kowloon
on the Kowloon side of Hong Kong this is
an area that is popular with Chinese
tourists they are marching towards a
train station where the trains from
China arrive so it is on the one hand
also
a way of raising or an F attempt to
raise awareness among mainland Chinese
who have been caught off by their own
media from these protests right you know
as you well know on Monday similar
protests turned violent when protesters
ransacked the legislature what can we
expect today well people do not expect
violence today you could see this right
away at the beginning people were coming
bringing their children elderly people
were joining this is not the environment
where violence happens the organizers of
this March individuals politicians who
have got the the police approval for
this March they have also said there
will be no violence today it's about
making a statement it's awesome about
making a statement that Monday's
storming of the legislature was a
punctual action an action that targeted
only the legislature and that this vile
this movement is not turning into a
broader rioting movement or anything
Matthias Bollinger in Hong Kong thank
you so much